[Musica]
server and security perché venendo
presto occupare tutto sommato se
lavorate in azienda c'è qualcuno che
viene pagato preoccuparsi al posto
vostro
e a casa chi volete che gli attacchi per
le formazioni che gestite e purtroppo
non ha perso in questo modo per me cyber
security un problema di dimensioni
decisamente più ampie significa che ogni
volta che un'azienda viene attaccata
vengono persi dei soldi nella perso del
denaro che magari serviva per fare
innovazione serviva per fare ricerca e
sviluppo magari serve per pagare i bonus
di fine anno e poi quanto abbiamo letto
negli ultimi mesi di elezioni politiche
che sono state compromesse siti di
partiti politici che sono stati
attaccati quindi permettetemi di
definirlo un problema sociale che ci
riguarda tutti quanto riguarda me
riguarda mia moglie e mia figlia
i miei amici mio vicino di casa ci
riguarda tutti quanti figuratevi su
scala internazionale ed è per questo che
sono estremamente preoccupato perché
stiamo sottovalutando il problema a
partire dalla radice lo percepiamo nel
modo sbagliato
a partire dagli oggetti che ci
circondano quotidianamente abbiamo tutti
in tasca uno smartphone
ora io ho un problema con la parola
smart perché se tu definisci
quell'oggetto smartphone
mi stai facendo pensare al telefono
della mia nonna quello grigio con la
rotella quei buchini e mi stai facendo
pensare che l'hanno fatto più piatto più
carino più simpatico
e invece no quello di non dovrebbe
chiamarsi smartphone io lo vorrei
chiamare stupidi si è un computer molto
piccolo con uno schermo molto piccolo ma
è un computer a tutti gli effetti
quante informazioni teniamo lì dentro
che ci riguardano e le proteggiamo con
meno attenzione di quanto cerchiamo di
proteggere le informazioni che teniamo
sui nostri computer perché lo guardiamo
e vediamo un elettrodomestico questo il
problema che io vedo non ho la
televisione a casa se io domani volessi
comprare una televisione non potrei
farlo
le televisioni 1 le costruiscono pilone
esistono più esistono le smart tv di
nuovo permettetemi non ha niente a che
vedere con quell'oggetto che va il tubo
catodico nel salotto dei miei genitori
quello io lo chiamerei idioti si è un pc
piccolissimo con uno schermo enorme a
delle funzionalità meravigliose no
quelli puoi parlare va avanti e ddc
volume su volume giù
canale avanti canale indietro meraviglia
peccato mi avvisano i costruttori di
questi oggetti che la televisione non
può sapere in anticipo se io gli sto
dando un comando o se sto parlando gli
affari miei
qui nel dubbio cosa fa prende la mia
voce la manda al sito del produttore che
la elabora sia un comando dice la
televisione dice di eseguirlo
altrimenti la copia della mia voce viene
buttata via
quindi ci avvisano la sera sul divano
con vostra moglie non parlate di cose
riservate davanti alla tv altrimenti una
copia della vostra voce mentre state
dicendo quelle cose attraverserà tutta
internet e per una certa quantità di
tempo potrebbe essere ascoltata da
qualcuno io mentre leggo queste cose
penso al 1984 di orwell e penso che
almeno loro non fortunati glieli
installavano a forza con gli apparecchi
invece le compriamo oppure usando i
nostri soldi
quindi il problema delle informazioni e
della loro gestione è grave lo vorrei
raccontare invitandovi a guardare questo
film è uno dei film che parlano di
hecking in maniera più corretta che
abbia mai visto un film del 1992 cercate
di collocarlo temporalmente pensate a
che automobile avevate nel 92 a che
computer a che telefono e fanno dire al
cattivo ad un certo punto che nostro
mondo non è più dominato dalle armi
dall'energia dei soldi ha dominato da
piccoli 10 da beat dadati tutto e solo
elettronica arrivano a fargli dire c'è
una guerra mondiale la fuori e non
vincerà chi ha più pallottole ha
importanza chi controlla le informazioni
quello che vediamo quello che sentiamo
quello che pensiamo
si basa tutto sulle informazioni e io
credo profondamente in questa cosa ogni
tanto mostro qualcuno questa slide
indice porca miseria alessio hai ragione
vero guardato le aziende quanti soldi
guadagnano senza produrre nulla
esclusivamente elaborando informazioni
no non è questo il senso della slide
queste sono le aziende che hanno perso
più soldi a causa di attacchi
informatici ricevuti dalle loro fra
strutture a causa di informazioni perse
manipolate
altro qui è successo capite perché sono
preoccupato perché per affrontare il
problema in questo momento stiamo
utilizzando proprio l'approccio
sbagliato la nostra strategia è
fallimentare perché perché come diceva
sun tzu conosci il tuo nemico lo diceva
nell'arte della guerra se vuoi vincere
la guerra devi partire dal conoscere chi
ti sta attaccando noi non lo conosciamo
è un problema grandissimo io non posso
più andare la mattina al bar a fare
colazione senza essere bersagliato dal
giornale di carta da una quantità di
notizie che parlano gli hacker hanno
rubato la carta di credito di quale foto
di là hanno bucato gli altri serve
dietro c'è la mia mamma mentre legge con
la roba di visualizza quello che la
televisione ci ha insegnato negli ultimi
trent'anni adolescente maschio bianco
con l'acne problemi relazionali digita
molto velocemente sulla tastiera facendo
succedere cose tecnologiche su internet
ha e deve avere una felpa nera con
cappuccio altrimenti che crei una brutta
notizia purtroppo lei che ha raccontato
così non s'è mai esistito
non esiste se stiamo basando la nostra
difesa sul difenderci da lui falliremo
permettetemi di sentire sintetizzare chi
ci sta attaccando utilizzando questo
schema
il risultato di una ricerca che ho
portato avanti con la divisione che si
occupa dei crimini contro l'umanità
dell'onu
la cosa che si avvicina di più alle car
al quale pensiamo è quello in alto a
destra
la spia industriale è sicuramente molto
competente e attacca qualcuno perché ha
un interesse c'è un attacco mirato
attacco una casa farmaceutica per rubare
la forma di una medicina che non è
ancora stata messa in commercio perché
guadagnare dei soldi ci stiamo
preoccupando di quello che qualcosa che
permettetemi di dire sì è vero a casa
non riattaccherà mai e probabilmente chi
non film non si occupa dei temi di cui
mi occupo io per lavoro non ha gli
strumenti per poterlo contrastare ma non
ci stiamo preoccupando invece il
problema più grave quello che sta al
centro del grafico quello di parlarvi
oggi la criminalità organizzata che ha
capito che su internet si possono fare
un sacco di soldi e quindi ha creato
quello che oggi chiamiamo cybercrime e
hanno un modello di business
permettetemi di raccontarli come se
fossero un azienda perché esattamente
questa la realtà basa completamente
diverso basato sulla statistica
attaccano tutti indifferentemente non
sanno chi stanno attaccando attacco
orizzontalmente sapendo che comunque dei
soldi li porteranno a casa
alessio si è molto simpatico però non mi
hai convinto ma come attaccano chiunque
come fanno pensatelo su fenomeni che
conoscete tutti quanti
il phishing quanto ml ricevete che
pretendono di arrivare dalla vostra
banca e li invitano a cliccare qualche
link mettere nome utente e la password
per farli rubare loro non hanno la
benché minima idea se destinatari sono
disoccupati imprenditori impiegati
dirigenti della multinazionale
se uno c'è il conto in rosso piuttosto
che ai milioni di euro sul conto lo
mandano a chiunque perché di media
siccome l'otto per cento delle persone
clicca su questa cosa lascia le sue
credenziali allora guadagnano del denaro
quindi mi preoccupano le dimensioni di
questo fenomeno
permettetemi di e farvi vedere qualche
numero che viene dal rapporto clusit
un'associazione che dal 2001 si occupa
in italia di creare consapevolezza circa
i rischi che la tecnologia porta con sé
pubblica ogni anno un rapporto che
racconta cosa succede in italia vi
vorrei sintetizzare qualche centinaia di
pagine in una slide non importa chi sei
non importa che cosa stai facendo non
importa con quale strumento lo stai
facendo
sei sotto attacco in questo momento
finché io sto parlando con voi il mio
telefono viene attaccato perché perché è
collegato ad internet insieme a tutti i
vostri quello che mi preoccupa di questo
fenomeno è che stiamo attribuendo a quel
10 per cento verdino l'asp industriale
l'importanza maggiore cerchiamo di
difenderci da quelle non ci stiamo
preoccupando del 75 per cento delle
cause degli incidenti più gravi che si
sono verificati recentemente che
peraltro sono anche i più facili da cui
difendersi perché l'abbiamo visto in
quel grafico molto spesso si basano su
tecniche assolutamente banali quello che
mi preoccupa di questo non è
esclusivamente il valore assoluto di
questo fenomeno ma il suo andamento
quelle barrette che continuano a
crescere sapete che cosa mi dicono che
se oggi abbiamo deciso che mandiamo una
e mail perché sono facili sono veloci
sulle economiche se quella barra arriva
ad un certo punto noi decideremo che è
molto più economico mandare una lettera
di carta con francobollo
là dentro una cassetta delle lettere
perché ci costerà meno che mandare una
mail
capite perché sono preoccupato perché
chi ci attacca a un comportamento
virtuoso studiano innovano trovano fanno
ricerca e sviluppo trovano nuovi modi
per attaccarci e per guadagnare più
soldi
qualche esempio vai alla festa della
birra e trovi sotto al tergicristallo
della tua auto un volantino di carta che
dice weber una birra gratis vieni allo
stand numero 6 con il coupon per
ottenere il coupon devi fare una foto al
qr code quel grazioso quadratino nero
con un'applicazione che ti porta su un
sito web che dovrebbe darti il coupon
bene quello un sito web creato dal
criminale per infettare un telefono non
particolarmente aggiornato
mi spiegate come racconto la mia mamma
che un foglio di carta le ha infettato
il telefono è un passaggio culturalmente
molto difficile
me ne rendo assolutamente assolutamente
conto e così le stesse cose possono
succedere con il fax ti arriva un fax
con un link tours digiti sul pc e
finisci su un sito pensato per affettare
il tuo pc
la carta sono bravissimi perché fanno
queste cose io non voglio entrare nel
merito del 23 mila dollari offerta un
dipendente apple per ottenere il suo
nome utente e la tua password
quelle che digita la mattina per
collegarsi in ufficio siano tanti o
pochi però questo mi racconta che c'è
qualcuno che ha pensato del che cosa
fare di quell'informazione quanti soldi
ci può guadagnare qualche indici di
rischio e di conseguenza ha deciso quale
l'investimento che disposto a fare
mentre io vado a parlare con
alcune aziende che non hanno idea del
quanto valgono le loro informazioni e di
conseguenza non sono in grado di
calcolare quanto sono disposti ad
investire per proteggerli capite perché
sono preoccupato perché anche quando
chiedo qual è la cosa peggiore che ti
può succedere a valle di un attacco e
molto spesso non arriva la risposta gli
informatici non avevano neanche la
parola per descrivere che cosa poteva
succedere succedere l'abbiamo dovuto
rubare agli in forma al mondo
dell'economia
il black swan un investimento di cui era
stato detto probabilità che vada male
impossibile bassissime ma dovesse andare
male le conseguenze finanziarie
sarebbero così grandi così catastrofiche
da costringere l'azienda a chiudere
perché non saprebbe reggere il colpo
ecco abbiamo dovuto rubare la parola
black swan per poter descrivere un
attacco informatico così grave che ha
costretto un'azienda a chiudere non
aveva una parola per raccontarlo oggi un
fenomeno in crescita
chiedetelo ad equi fax un'azienda che fa
credi cech statunitense qualche
settimana fa ha subito un'intrusione gli
hanno rubato 160 mila i dati di 160 mila
clienti meno 35 per cento del valore
delle azioni in borsa in una settimana
meno 35 per cento mi dite quante aziende
saprebbero reggere un colpo del genere
mi dicono che la manipolazione delle
informazioni esposta tantissimo denaro
si era convincente ma nell'aprile 2013
ho capito quanto denaro poteva spostare
qualcuno indovina e la password
la password capite che la complessità
dell'attacco st 0 gli associate presso
immaginate l'ansa statunitense e
lanciano una notizia falsa esplose due
bombe alla casa bianca
ferito il presidente degli stati uniti
andamento della borsa col giorno
ora questo non è un ragazzino che stava
giocando questa si chiama manipolazione
del mercato azionario perché intanto
andato a chiedere la gente che ha perso
i soldi li si è perso del denaro
digitale virtuale o altro credo che
farebbe delle espressioni orribili e in
più se è molto chiaro che è che stava
perdendo il denaro li parliamo del chi
lo stava guadagnando qui capite di che
costano parlando una quantità di denaro
enorme che viene spostata
un altro esempio quante aziende si
potrebbero permettere di perdere 3
milioni
dollari one shot qui mi permettete di
raccontarvi questa truffa
arriva una mail che dice di essere di un
collega del tuo capo di responsabile di
un'altra business unit della tua azienda
che ti chiede di fare un bonifico molto
velocemente d'urgenza il bonifico viene
fatto l'avete letto sulle prime pagine
dei giornali nei giorni scorsi succede
anche in italia succede nostre aziende e
per importo importantissimi per questo
io sono preoccupatissimo perché questo è
un problema che in qualche modo dobbiamo
affrontare e allora che cosa possiamo
fare
mi permetto di rispondervi facendovi
vedere la foto della macchina che
guidava il mio papà alla fine degli anni
70 una lancia fulvia andava come un
missile
mi piaceva moltissimo però è un'auto che
una le cinture
ma la biesse con l'airbag che userebbe
oggi per fare un lungo viaggio
beh nessuno però ci abbiamo messo
trent'anni a capirlo all'epoca era
assolutamente in linea con la dotazione
tecnologica all'avanguardia
ho una brutta notizia voi su questo non
avete nessun controllo non siete voi a
creare gli strumenti non siete voi a
scrivere software non siete voi a fare i
telefoni dovete fidarvi che venga fatto
nel modo corretto pro voi avete un'altra
responsabilità perché la mia auto che
oggi è molto diversa da questa
addirittura sensori telecamere c'è una
tazzina del caffè che mi lampeggia sul
cruscotto per dirmi che tengo il volante
in maniera stanca mi devo fermare a fare
una pausa
beh se io però quell'auto la guida 200
all'ora ubriaco bendato nel cuore della
notte sulla strada di campagna mi farò
malissimo per certo indipendentemente
dalla caratteristiche dell'auto chiedere
ai tecnici che non succeda qualche cosa
e come chiedere al meccanico di non fare
un incidente il meccanico si può
assicurare che i freni frenino ma il
pedale e sotto il vostro controllo
allora purtroppo io non potrò scendere
da questo palco
lasciandovi un elenco del dovete avere
un antivirus deve essere aggiornato
dovete usare una password su ogni sito
che usate deve essere diversa dovete
cambiarla con una certa frequenza
dovete tenere aggiornati gli strumenti
che avete cioè sono tutte cose
indispensabili ma non sufficienti solo
nozioni che dovete apprendere per creare
la vostra consapevolezza circa il
problema è quella consapevolezza creerà
la vostra etica che influenzerà il
vostro comportamento
se vogliamo arrivare in un mondo di
arcobaleni magici e dorati dove tutte le
informazioni sono gestite nel modo
migliore
purtroppo abbiamo una responsabilità
enorme
se esiste uno strumento per farlo quello
strumento siete voi è l'unica chance che
abbiamo per vorrei raccontare in questo
modo una volta qualche settimana fa ero
in auto con zaia verona stavo tornando
alla pulitura a secco è andato a
prendere un abito e mentre attraversava
un semaforo
uno è passato con osceni appeso sulla
portiera avevo in macchina mia moglie e
mia figlia in quel momento vi assicuro
che quando a loro in macchina sono
sempre molto prudente non supera mai il
limite di velocità quindi facevo 50
all'ora se c'è arancione io mi fermo
quindi sono passato col verde e non ho
nessun controllo sul fatto di impedire
che qualcuno mi colpisca sulla portiera
però facevo 50 all'ora e mia figlia
nonostante papi la cintura mi dà
fastidio era legata sul seggiolino
questo ha permesso che ci siamo trovati
a discutere del fatto del chi paga al
paraurti chi paga la portiera e non a
fare una corsa in ospedale quindi il
vostro comportamento è fondamentale per
influenzare l'impatto che possono avere
questi attacchi su di voi e per
difendere in modo corretto su internet
gli esperti ne parlano quotidianamente
non sapete dove rivolgervi chiedete a
clusit che l'indirizzo da qualche parte
ma le informazioni ci sono e siete voi
che dovete costruire con la
consapevolezza e lo state già facendo
siete venuti qui oggi grazie
[Applauso]